(sad piano music)
(gagging)
- Oh God.
It's like eating a pimple.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] Oh God.
- I hope you don't want
me to eat sushi in this,
because I probably won't.
- Crayfish can be really...
- Squishy.
- It's a little too chewy for me.
- Gushy.
- Something about textures,
really disgust me.
- I (beep) hate tuna.
- Pig.
- I (beep) hate fish.
- Burgers.
- I don't like squash.
- Bacon.
- Onions.
- Sushi.
- I don't like green beans.
- Peppers.
- Zucchini.
- Bananas.
- When people call me a picky eater,
it makes me think that I'm a snob,
but I'm not a snob, I just
like the foods that I like.
(upbeat music)
- This is a radish.
Never had one before.
Eww.
- I'm gonna give the
tofu mushroom a go now.
Mushrooms should only
be consumed by Mario.
Eatin' a rubber band.
- Mushrooms not bad, I
thought I hated mushrooms.
- Usually after my fitness class,
I get a bagel with cream cheese.
Today I'm gonna be adventurous
and get like turkey bacon.
It's not disgusting, but it's not good.
- [Voiceover] Oh, that's cute.
They put salad with my fried chicken.
(dramatic) opera music)
- Oh God.
It smells like the ocean,
it smells so disgusting.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] No?
- So gross.
Feels like the fish is trying to
crawl back up my throat and get out.
That was maybe the worst thing
I've ever put in my mouth.
- I almost threw up.
(laughter)
Oww (beep).
- That doesn't belong in the mouth.
- Taste like I'm eating my own tongue.
(laughter)
- It's like angry glue.
It does not want to be swallowed.
Oww it's (beep) alive.
- At the Homeless Tahini.
I'm gettin' green, the
absolute worst color for food.
I conquered it.
I conquered, none of it's in the trash.
- I'm trying brussels
sprouts for the first time.
- Friends have always made fun of me
because I've never had a tuna melt.
(laughter)
- Wow.
- Indian food.
The craziest thing about this is
I don't even know what I have.
Let's try it, I might finish
it like I did yesterday.
We'll see.
Indian food, it ain't bad.
I don't know what it is, again,
don't know what it is but it ain't bad.
(dramatic music)
- This is a (beep) oyster.
I spit it out, oh God I almost threw up.
- The alcohol won't even
get rid of the taste.
I need like five more shots.
This is fucking snails.
- It taste like butter, I
didn't really taste the snail.
It wasn't bad.
- It doesn't taste that
much different than,
any other meat covered in butter.
So like, it's actually okay.
- Not as bad as I thought.
(laughter)
I was very proud of myself.
That was maybe the hardest
thing I ever done in my life.
And I told my whole family about it.
They were all very proud.
- I'm really happy that I
tried a bunch of new foods.
I think too often in life we
get stuck in our own routines.
I wanna continue trying new foods.
- If I took anything away from this week,
it would be that, I shouldn't let my,
experiences as a kid effect
my pallet as an adult.
- My advice to picky eaters,
just stick to what you're used
to except for Indian food.
Try Indian food.
Indian food is so good,
shout out to India.